>> Well, I believe the answer yes.
I believe India can and will become a superpower
over the next 3 to
4 decades.
What is important is leadership.
Leadership both for the private and public
sectors of the country.
And you know, my perspective obviously is
one of leadership, running
one of the executive search firms that place
leaders around the globe.
And, um, if you have the right environment
to foster leadership and
look at this right from the schooling, all
the way through initial
campus equipment and then training of management
and leadership through
corporations and the public sector, when you
have sufficient amount of
leaders, who have the momentum to move forward,
and this country will
definitely then become a superpower.